thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
hi
I'm Tyrus Cooper
360.
look I know you're upset and rightfully
so
you just saw the Durham report which
proved that there was no evidence to
support any investigation with Russian
collusion and Trump
the feeling it's like being neutered and
speaking of being neutered Greg is off
tonight because he's taking his dog to
get snipped
sorry Gus
but better you than me
but yeah the Durham report and you're
asking how did this happen
and I wouldn't blame you if you never
watched CNN or MSNBC again
and judging by the ratings you're not
because you're pissed
pissed we got catfished America
it's like they sent you a picture of
Scarlett Johansson and when you went to
meet for dinner it was Anna Navarro
it was years of wasting taxpayers
millions of dollars investigating
something that was all I don't know how
they say it
and how did this all start
because when we saw Trump speaking we
saw a guy speaking for the Common Man
challenging The Establishment he was
Brash in your face he told it like it is
and we liked it
but this is what the Liberals saw
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh yeah this isn't Greg's show anymore
it's mine tonight
so he hurt their little feelers
and the left and the media had to break
out the tissues luckily Jeffrey two burn
already had some handy
one guy at tubing fan in here
I think toilet paper would be way better
because let's be honest they're all
fully
but Durham's investigation was based on
facts facts not feelings
remember every day there was some
breaking news in how the president was a
Russian agent it was how do they put it
worse than Watergate
this is far worse than Watergate why
this is worse than Watergate is worse
than Watergate this in some ways is
worse than Watergate I keep getting
asked are there Echoes of Watergate in
this and there are
and he was right this was worse than
Watergate but the Bad actors weren't
from the Trump Administration and
speaking of Bad actors remember this
Michael Flynn promised full cooperation
to the Mueller team
and is prepared to testify that as a
candidate Donald Trump directed him to
make contact with the Russians
he goes to jail he goes to jail
[Applause]
but even when their stories started to
fall apart they kept it going like any
good catfish they pretended their camera
phone was broken and that's why they
couldn't FaceTime you America
heck even Manti Teo could tell you this
was a catfish
oh you saw the documentary
so who was
who was this
they wanted us to believe it was a big
naughty redhead that was going around is
going to ruin the world do all kinds of
bad things to us turns out that catfish
was
hey
hey we don't boo here
but for this one time you may boo
all right back to being nice hey look if
the pantsuit fits
Hillary Clinton you owe Russia an
apology
and there should be an apology tour for
lying to the American people and ruining
two years of Trump's presidency and
affecting elections with Russia gate
impeachment and fake dossiers oh yeah
let's not forget the P tape turns out it
was the Democrats and the Lefty media
peeing down our backs and telling it was
rain
or what Jim Norton calls the 40 special
[Laughter]
but don't expect a retraction or an
apology held already doubling down
this is a predictable sad ending to an
investigation that never should have
taken place Durham is a is a kind of
pathetic character he basically to me
copied and pasted or plagiarized from
the oig report that was the whole thing
is predicated on it it's like a rabbit
hole conspiracy there's nothing new here
we knew from the very beginning this was
never a legitimate investigation and
what you have with John Durham is like
it's a big fat nothing because there is
no there there
oh there's there there
but expect more the same they'll just
change the straight up false narratives
and probably say he's a white
supremacist welcome to the club
so why did all this happen easy because
he kicked in the door to their safe
spaces and just like Rick James on
Charlie Murphy's couch he put his muddy
shoes all over and said yo couch and
heal feelings
and then to make matters worse he then
walked into the bathroom took a dump in
their toilet and at the dinner party
then hollowed out no one go in there he
dropped to Steve Ducey
that was for you Greg
well actually Gus
he told it like it was he exposed the
swamp he exposed the media and the
corrupt politicians and the high-ranking
members of the FBI
and then they conspired to get his ass
out of office
now look I'm not a rocket surgeon but
that looks pretty rigged to me
Fire
Let's welcome tonight's guess
Three's a Crowd according to his ticket
sales comedian Joe DeVito
I love you I was one of those three
she survived life in socialist Wasteland
known as ESPN I'll kick host Charlie
Arnold
[Applause]
the only four-letter word not in his act
is hair
comedian the co-host of the Jim Norton
and Sam Roberts show The One and Only
Jim Norton
was by cat and you should go buy her new
book this is this the part where Greg
would say something mean
Charlie welcome to the show thank
you we started this hot fire tonight uh
do you think that uh Trump
is Vindicated or is there a lot more
that they need to do than this no he's
absolutely exonerated even our good
friend on the left Jake Tapper was
forced to admit it which we all love to
hear right it's always nice to have
people admit that they've been wrong for
what now eight years uh there's so many
outrageous aspects of what we just
discovered with the Durham report being
released uh the first and foremost was
there was absolutely no basis for it in
the first place the investigation should
have never have taken place but now that
the findings have been released and
Trump has in fact been exonerated
Liberals are doing everything possible
to try and delegitimize the findings uh
they're doing it in a few different ways
they have a few power plays we all know
one is oh it's a conspiracy theory uh
they've already started rattling off
those thoughts already uh the other is
the fact that they say because there
wasn't a whole slew of indictments after
the findings were released that this
actually isn't legit but we all know the
swamp protects its own and I think
there's a couple of really important
things to focus on here one being that
former FBI director James Comey wasn't
even interviewed for a single moment
throughout the course of the
investigation the other is the timing of
the report six months after the midterms
that's a long time you know speaking of
catfish Joe have you ever been catfished
I have I've been chatting with someone
now I'm pretty sure is a Russian bot but
it's going well
good for you good for you
do you think do you think that calling
this a catfish is an accurate
description to the American people I you
know it is it is a bit of a weird magic
trick that they've done where they took
a a fake Scandal and promoted that and
they took a real scandal with a real
laptop from a real president's real
pervert horny crackhead son with real
messages showing he was peddling his
family's influence and that's the one
they suppressed they did a nice little
Switcheroo there I've never understood
this idea that Donald Trump was supposed
to be a Russian spy because what do you
look for in a spy someone who keeps a
low profile yep right not not someone
who puts his name on buildings and has
TV shows and things like that and I
think there's a lot of reasons to not
like Donald Trump even if you're a
supporter of his but it's like bringing
extra food to the buffet he gave you
plenty to work with you didn't have to
make stuff up which is what they did
Hillary Clinton still saying the 2016
election's been stolen no one calls her
an election denier no well no one talks
to her either that's probably why cat as
a Libertarian this has got to just grind
your gear it's just so it's been nice to
have some company in criticizing the FBI
yeah oh yeah finally yeah finally
everyone I'm like oh Republicans okay
you guys do all right
um but I I'm just thinking like how will
this
you know be talked about in history
books and I actually mean that literally
because this whole thing started with a
rumor about a p tape
yeah like that's how it started how are
people going to write about that because
that's what happened because as soon as
I heard that I was like come on that's
nobody it's not like a big uh offense to
Obama by peeing on a bed that he already
stayed on right so I feel like Trump
would be better at Revenge than that
yeah
um and I just think that it has to be at
this point the most expensive rumor in
the history of rumors
yeah Millions yeah the p-tape rumor and
then there was the investigation and
then the investigation into the
investigation of the investment it all
started with the rumor about a p-tape
yeah and there's going to be another
investigation of the investigation of
the investigation yeah the whole slew of
Investigations
I'm Gonna Leave it to you you know what
as timing is everything
and it is kind of weird that Hunter was
that was dead they had him dead to
rights and there was supposedly going to
be an indictment any day now and now
there is no indictment and it's all back
to 24 7 Trump again do you think that's
a coincidence no and I I have to correct
your monologue I hate to do that but uh
peeing down my back has not been a 40
special since 1988. is it up oh yeah
that's right inflation you thought it
was just talking right yeah uh yeah I
think so I mean uh and Hunter Biden I
mean like you know I I if I was the
president's son I'd probably behave a
lot more like him then I would like
Chelsea Clinton or Donald Trump Jr I
relate to Hunter Biden I would probably
do the same things he did and if I was a
president I'd probably be Trump and have
sex with Stormy Daniels I understand I
don't know why these people don't get
along they're all the same they are all
the same I relate to all of them I think
the I think the biggest thing in cat
it's like I don't think any they can't
share anything like they can't it has to
be one there can only be one it's like
the old movie how Islander which you
never saw but I'm hoping that you two
guys saw where there could only be one
there is no they do the exact same
things but they blame other people for
what other people do have you ever been
in that situation to where someone you
knew they did it but they blamed you for
it anyway uh gaslighting at its finest
of course all the time well that's the
way I think also that that's what keeps
people in power is that the people in
power play us against each other in the
two-party system and like human chess
yep what you're describing is my
relationship that's exactly what that is
something happens she does it and the
next day it's like you were so mean to
me I'm like shut up and I'm like oh yeah
now I'm being mean to you yeah
The Narcissist world we live in all
right before we go I've got a big
announcement
my new book nuff said comes out this
November and is now available for
pre-order yes I'm topless again so head
over to Amazon or Barnes and Nobles and
reserve your copy today
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else